politics behind the corona virus
pandemic has been the source of
inspiration for one committee Michael
Spicer Twitter's favorite fictional
advisor has gone viral with his online
sketches where he speaks into the
imaginary earpieces of the world's most
important leaders like this one a lot of
people are getting better no they're not
they're doing very well all of them are
doing well now you're doing that thing
where you exaggerate every time you open
your mouth so stop doing that we're very
well organized very well organized we
have great talent we have great talented
doctors great doctors great great great
everyone
Jodee the size the chameleon behind the
room next door sketches Michael Spicer
and we recognize that sofa don't we
hello to you Michael Spicer thanks for
joining us superstar where did you come
up with the idea and I came up with the
idea uh yeah I was watching Boris
Johnson give an interview when he was
running for leader and and and he was
asked what what does he like to do in
his spare time and he said that he
paints model buses so the the aren't the
answer he gave was just so muddled and
confused and it felt like he was
struggling with that answer like he
thought well shall I confess that I do
this or shall I lie and it just it just
seemed to me that there would there
could potentially be somebody in the
room next door
feeding him those lines and really kind
of struggling with it
so but that that's that's all I did I
just did a sketch after I saw it okay
who was the inspiration behind your
character was the one no no it's just
that it was literally an afterthought i
I I thought that would be funny and I
mean that's usually what I do when I
when I do sketches I just think yeah
I'll do it because you know it's easy to
do it'll make people know if I can put
it on Twitter and see what happens
I had no idea this will happen you say
it's easy to do but there must be a lot
of work that goes into it yeah well yes
yes no that's true a lot of work that's
going to it but and I've done quite a
few sketches in the past and I'm aware
of my limit
so I kind of you know I've got my iMovie
on a laptop I film everything on my
phone I've invested in the tripod so
that's great but yeah basically it's
just it's just me at home so basically I
was doing lockdown stuff years before we
were in lockdown that's it and you say
that you've invested in a tripod I mean
you're a bit of a superstar now you'd be
able to pay for that very easily did I
not see you on The Late Late Show
yes you did um yeah I mean that money
still country yeah anyway you know you
know it's the same things that I've been
able to quit my job which is like the
dream isn't it so the the strange thing
is is that I left my job and then
started working from home and then a
week later everyone else in the world
did so a very peculiar time for this to
be happening really and you decided to
write a book yes yes I well somebody
said from publishing company said if
you're thinking of writing a book I'd be
very interested in publishing it so yeah
my brain started ticking over and I
thought what would make a good book and
it it will essentially be like a journal
but there will be lots of other things
in there so it will feel like a like a
file full of emails and texts and
scripts with doodles on them and all
sorts so it's a comedy book really
because what you do is very visual so
how are you going to translate that into
a book or it's something completely
different is it it is different it is
different I mean you know obviously if
people buy my book so know what my
sketches are like and so they're
probably read with my voice and then
hopefully I don't be there for the comic
timing but if they if they buy the books
I'm sure they enjoy it well we're
looking forward to seeing that that's
out later on in the year isn't it I mean
if you had to choose a favorite of the
spoofs that you do which one would it be
up-to-date um I don't really have a
favorite but I would probably choose the
Priti Patel interview because to date it
is the most successful I mean it really
went berserk so that has a special place
in my heart
okay well we'll see if we can dig that
one out for our viewers but it's good to
talk to you thank you so much for
joining us we really appreciate it
love when the video when Selectric
coming out well I did one last night for
for the Late Late Show
and if it's funny then I imagine they'll
put it on next week if it's not funny
you won't see it at all
okay I'll bear that in mind it's good to
talk to you Michael thanks very much
indeed we have managed to find them
pretty much tell one it looks something
like this clear history in relation to
counter terrorism offenses terrorism
offenses not counterterrorism offenses
you have brainless wasp greater support
for victims and greater support for the
victims of counterterrorism terrorism
terrorism why can't you just say it it's
easier to say